italian architect renzo piano has a
vision for the new california academy of
sciences while he works on the design
from home local architect khong gian
must turn pianos dreams into reality
it's a daunting task many wonder is it
even possible I realized that I gotta
need a lot of help yes it's gonna be
challenging it's gonna be fun but it's
gonna be challenging Renzo Piano
originally wanted the Piazza roof to
sweep all the way down to the ground
with the roof coming down to the Piazza
we have we have several challenges and
what happens with would rain water
coming into the Piazza if it doesn't
we're gonna have another aquarium okay
we'll have a pawn in the middle and
Piazza quarter here changes have to be
made and Keon predicts more problems
will arise once construction begins made
a template and you also have to have the
rain forest and the planetarium be
completed before the roof goes on
because if you can't get to it in the
future after many months the design for
the new California Academy of Sciences
is finally finished its creation will
require a diverse team of architects
engineers builders and scientists
separated by thousands of miles to work
together hand in hand collectively they
must find a way to build the impossible
a mega structure made of glass sitting
in a seismic strike zone out of the dust
a museum begins to rise
one that is truly dream despite its
appearance the concrete is partly
recycled fly ash a byproduct of
coal-fired power plants even the
insulation in the walls is recycled from
shredded denim we are in San Francisco
the city of blue jeans so we used the
blue jeans denim to make the thermal
installation one hundred percent of the
steel in the building is recycled
construction proceeds rapidly
there's only a couple of months before
the winter rains come
and everything must be undercover as
kyon predicted renzo piano's design
poses a sequencing problem for the team
when you got plants on top of Steel on
top of planetarium on top of water on
top of the structure on top of
foundation it's a unique one-of-a-kind
isn't one where you could say oh I built
one of those you know a year ago or two
years ago or five years ago here's how
you do it this is when it hasn't been
built for it's more than two years since
the builders broke ground with crews
sometimes exceeding five hundred people
a day at last the basic structure of
this Noah's Ark is complete now they
need to see if it works viewed from the
air the mysterious roof of greens seems
to rise above the park like magic from
the first day was really dead yet to
make the roof like a flying carpet like
like a piece of the bat flying home to
20 million specimens and thousands of
living animals it's a 21st century
Noah's Ark made of glass
it's an architectural marvel like no
other on the planet